this is a dj duck exclusive exclusive
welcome to another thankful thursday i
believe it's important to thank the
people in your life in your business who
help you grow because you can't do this
on your own you can't reach your dreams
by yourself and it's nice just to say
thank you every now and then to the
people who help you along your journey
so today i want to say a big thank you
to dj doc now dj duck is a toronto based
dj who's award-winning latin dj and
producer plays some sick tracks mix them
up himself and then also dj's amount for
people to enjoy
and uh
he
really
helps me in a lot of different ways so i
first met him
through the school that i've i'm an
investor in toronto dance salsa and i
i like to dj so most of the events for
the school i'll dj and it's something
that's really rewarding for me and
something that that's really special
when you see people out there on the
floor dancing to the music that you're
putting out there i don't know just
makes you feel makes me feel great and
so i keep doing it but i'm not always
able to be at every event because i've
got a pretty crazy schedule between
speaking and traveling there's a lot of
events that i miss and dj doc is the
first person i call on to say doc
i'm speaking in vancouver at this event
can you cover for me at the bachata
social and almost always he says bro i'm
there i got you covered and so i'm so
grateful to have somebody of that
caliber willing to step in duck has
become a great friend he he came to to
my wedding we've done a lot of different
collaborations together we have dance
offs to see who can dip the girl lower
and he's the only
non-evan carmichael team member right
now to own one of the believe shirts so
it's an honor doc so doc i want to say
thank you
i know you got my back always i really
appreciate it and
and uh from bottom of my heart thank you
so much and for those of you watching
take time to thank somebody today who's
had an impact on your life your business
somebody you can count on someone who's
helping you reach for your dreams send
them an email make a video
call them up take them the coffee
surprise them with a treat write them a
handwritten note whatever it is just say
thank you you'll feel better they'll
feel great and uh you'll continue to
grow your business
believe you can check out duck on on
facebook on youtube on soundcloud on
twitter
and uh if you guys like this video
subscribe to the channel you'll see more
just like it
this is dj ducks
big shout out to jb music
every week i share my best information
to help you fuel your business forward
in my newsletter check it out below
hi i'm jason j ross fonseca of
risonline.com and i want to say evan
carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's the only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to period